as we all know I invited my cousin Zach
to join the fantasy football league
can't we just play with seven is this
right spot Kyle what's up man
hey thanks for letting me join the
league this year yeah trust me wasn't my
decision give him a chance
maybe he'll end up being your best
friend Ryan was my best friend where
Ryan left you for Europe I'm having a
cool party this weekend you should roll
through hey Justin you're up for the
beer pong tournament I can't play guys
you know my regular partner is in Europe
I'll be your partner okay just don't get
in the way okay I don't want you messing
up my perfect record you were saying
whoa I'm not sure about this guy now
things are slowly changing he likes me
for me I think you should go there if
you don't I will
okay you know what I get it I'm gonna
talk to her I'm Justin I don't know what
I do this
one two three feel like we're losing
that ambition that drive you know like
when I have kids one day I want to be
say hey you could walk on the moon one
day you know you could be the next
Michael Jackson probably no I'm not
stupid
no it's not stupid Justin man I don't
know if I can hang out tonight I just
had a really stressful day at work and I
hey I got Beer Can Chicken going in the
oven and I got fast seven on blu-ray but
I understand if you want me to go this
is exactly what I needed
hello Justin Bryan I thought you're in
Europe I'm back now cheers right uh
who's this I'm Zach I'm Justin's new his
new friend and he made of Justin's is
made of money you know let me just take
off oh say oh no it's nice meeting you
you are my number one mate brother yeah
man hey
this is Justin I can't pick up right now
cuz check it out with his best friend it
has got that Riviera
you can Justin actually likes you
Cal Bears yo why don't you set the pig
it's really about the pig you bailed on
me
my stamps premier it's cool looks like
he had a good time it sounds just a good
time it's an important time this is when
we pick the people that we stay with or
the people that we leave behind I want
you to come with me to Europe Joey Nova
pom get in that pool monado and they put
a little tune around they're still so
weird seeing a menu in English Justin
what's going on man you haven't touched
your crepe I'm sorry I gotta go Justin
Oh knives available just really unknown
rocket consider
I feel
you know k Anya
Oh